when I've seen I've watched things with
you on YouTube where people attack you
for they'll attack you being
Islamophobic or that you're attacking
Islam or but clearly that's not the case
yeah I mean I mean the fact of the
matter is like you cannot you cannot
criticize Islam in most Muslim countries
so even here in the West they created
some sort of like catch-22 so if
somebody is a what is a white person
like Sam Harris or they immediately get
attack him as cisgender white male kinda
interesting to hear too from like
Muslims who don't believe in trans
rights and so there but if you have
somebody like me who is from the Middle
East you know immediately can attack him
as some sort of Uncle Tom mass murderer
so they create catch-22 is that in in
the middle in the Muslim world you
cannot criticize Islam and if you do it
in the West you will be you will be
labeled immediately as as some sort of
Raider as a traitor right so this is an
incredible thing to me so I've had my
genius on obviously yeah I think you
know magic knowledge meant of his latest
books so you know a little bit and he
gets this all the time yeah you gots it
more than I do it right so yeah it's
that he's a trader or he's an Uncle Tom
or he's a porch monkey I mean these guys
yeah and again that's we've talked about
this a lot but this is coming from
people on the left so what I don't
understand is if you believe in liberal
values and you want women to be free and
you want gay people to be free and all
those things and you want equality for
everybody how do they expect to get it
if not through people like you and my
dude forget forget Sam okay they want to
throw him under the bus of course I'm
not for that yeah what I'm saying is if
they want to just remove they want to
use their own version of bigotry to
remove him yeah like I fine but then
wouldn't they look at someone like you
that stands up for all those values on
the left and say this is a guy he
survived living yeah Saddam he now
fights to make his country and those
other countries stand up for the very
values that we as progressives say we're
full yeah and yet you don't get support
out of these guys do you yeah I mean I I
do get somebody but I know what you're
referring to is
the regressive left I imagine that was
yeah I mean it's very interesting I
called an holy Alliance that happened
between the liberal left and the Muslim
right against the the or Muslim or
secular left in the Arab world right and
so nautically the secular left just to
put that all together the secular left
is actually lined up in a weird way with
the conserve with the conservative right
yes which is very bonkers yeah it is
extremely I mean they don't say it very
publicly but the fact of the matter I
mean they apply extreme different
standards to I was speaking at UC
Berkeley before I came here and I've had
also some debates and in Northern
California and I told him like what do
you call a conservative Republican who
is against gay marriage and he said I
call him a bigot then he thank you for
calling ninety percent of Muslims bigots
then he said I never said that right
okay I told him if you apply different
standards different people based upon
the race and because they think that
Muslim is the brown technically right
you're not even raised yeah if you have
a few applied different people different
based upon their race then you're
actually a racist and this this form of
racism is sometimes get get because most
of the racism we talk about is like the
KKK and the fact of the matter is that
they agree so like when when somebody
like the Charleston shooting the one
happened in South Carolina is that the
guy said I'm motivated by racism and
they immediately took him for his word
and their true the the right that Jesus
guy was motivated by racism but replaced
God place this guy by Isis and Isis says
I am literally motivated by this
interpretation of Islam the same guys
who said that this game was believed by
racism will say no no this thing has
ulterior motives right it must be about
economics and foreign policy or politics
I'm George W Bush and Dick Cheney and
and they lump in all the they create the
salad of everybody they hate and they
put him in one category and so so you
see like the double standard is
extremely obvious and
so as a result of that they can you
created a smokescreen for apologist and
and an even extremists to flourish in
like people like me have to fight
against the religious right and the far
right in the United States who who
consider me like inferior a human being
right and have to fight the religious
right in my own country there's llama
cried and I said I have to fight the
apologist left so like they created
extra France war and they they have made
it very much very much difficult for
people like Majid Nawaz and many people
who are I mean reformers to actually
even have the discussion to begin with
because they don't think there is any
discussion that we had and it's all
about u.s. foreign policy and they
always try to divert the discussion is
all about America all about America I've
noticed now now that I followed more of
these people on Twitter and there's
probably a good maybe forty people like
yourself that are trying to yeah reform
and coming from these countries and
trying to make things better I see
people like you tweeting about
coexistence tweeting about how do we
make things better all that and I never
see it from the regressives yeah they
always are screaming about foreign
policy or whatever it is defending our
foreign policy that's that's not a
binary says it's not a binary so yeah
and yet so what is the angle what is it
that they're throwing back at you that
they can't get behind what you're doing
yeah I mean I mean that they think that
the biggest problem like so they see the
wall can some sort of like a pyramid so
the biggest problem in this world is
cisgender white male capitalists rich
and then briefly define cisgender I
didn't know what it was until about a
month ago I mean to I guess because I
got attacked because of it is this
gender because I'm cisgendered yeah this
means that you were born the gender that
your sexuality
yeah and that's now a privilege so I was
like I come from Iraq and my brother was
killed and I told me I'm privileged here
but anyway so they they have this
pyramid in which there is they see the
world based upon like race gender
and and financial privilege and they
think that the biggest problem this
planet is Western capitalism and they
link everything on this world into it's
a very American centric point of view
yeah is that they link everything
problem in this world as a problem so so
if if a if a brown person from Pakistan
wants to blow himself up to say to
defend Jerusalem quote-unquote they will
say that this is as a result of
imperialism happening by the motor
industrial complex connected to Western
capitalism so they always lump
everything to that and everything is an
expression of grievances so like you say
somebody's like I hate Jews and they say
like well I mean he doesn't literally
hate Jews but that is his language to
express his frustration with American
imperialism so so they always link
everything back to so that is there it's
there the point is like and then I can
people like nom Chomsky was like the
head of the of the movement I would say
I would have him on but I don't think
he'd like to talk to someone smarter
than him well I mean there I mean it's I
don't think it's I mean Sam tried to
engage with him and I don't think it's
it's you can actually have a
conversation is that it's I mean they
they seem to subscribe to a specific
dogma like I always try to like make the
base of my friends that I can like a
predict what Chomsky is gonna write just
by seeing the title of the article so
like I make five points I say this is
what chomps is gonna say in the in this
paragraph in this paragraph and I always
like get my $50 because I like what
exactly Chomsky is gonna write he's
gonna say that it's about American
imperialism is here say it's about the
grievances is gonna say about capitalism
and all these like you don't need to
read all his books either right like
right quite a lot but it seems like I've
read two books and all the riots were
like just just subscribe to the same so
is that the danger of these guys because
what they're doing even if a certain
percentage of what they're saying is
right about American foreign policy I I
had Douglas Mari on last week yeah who I
thought
said something that I had never thought
of before which was that he said you
know you Americans always think
everything's about you yeah that's what
you're saying that's what these guys are
doing but let's just say a certain
percentage I mean yes half-truths I mean
I mean many of them I mean look at for
example what what some apologists say is
that well they say like the majority of
Muslims don't support Isis this is true
but al-qaeda also doesn't support Isis
so the question of is do you support
Isis or not sayingnot doesn't me move
you to the moderate yeah you can
subscribe to a lot of beliefs that I
said you agree with Isis with and you
don't need a support Isis for example
Ayatollah whom I harmony in all of the
ayatollahs in Iran it is agree with Isis
but if you look at how they treat gays
in Iran is not that much different than
Isis select the disagreement they tell
you a truth which is the majority of
Muslims don't agree with Isis which is
true but that's half the truth they
don't tell you that there's a
significant amount of Egyptians and
Pakistanis and and and so many countries
around the Muslim world that thing that
penalty apostasy should be death right
so which is so that's I think like the
purest art that has been done on like
Sharia and what Muslims believe and I
ask everybody to read it was very
intelligent because it asks specific
questions it doesn't people as people
like all these support Isis or not or
this apart 9/11 or not but they ask them
like the questions do you think that
suicide bombing is an appropriate way of
dealing with the grievances and they you
see a significant amount saying yes yeah
and do you think it should be a lot of
killing these people who conspire with
the Americans and the Israelis
you know they will say yes and that a
significant amount will say yes so so
this so when somebody says so all of
these things even though some of the
parts are true I mean as I said like a
guy's foreign policy in Iraq has not
been very great and to say the least and
there are so many things that should
have been done that have not been done
and so yes United States foreign policy
have played a role in the rise of the
extremism in the Middle East but they
are not the root of a problem there is a
huge difference between and the reason
like it was
the moment he they agree like for
example on the abortion clinics that
like happened in United States they
agreed that this is a result of
religious fundamentalism right
many of the liberals agree that Mike
Huckabee and Ted Cruz and all of these
folks are moneywe are Christian
fundamentalist and they are worried
about them because they are Christian
fundamentalist but the moment that this
discussion goes into Islam the moment
that know the root of the fundamentalist
has nothing to do with the tags as
nothing to do with interpretation and
it's all about us is immediately goes in
back in this very self center like
egotistical point of view is that
everything is about the United States
it's not solving anything I mean I think
then I'm sorry you mentioned because
they are giving a free pass to these
people that me and others who are
fighting on daily basis they were
fighting against the theocrats
in our countries and and and the the
regressive light has given these people
free pass to telling them you know
there's nothing to do with it's all
about us do you think they consciously
aware of it because I've sort of
struggled with this question a bit and
when I've talked to people I I think a
lot of people I think Sam at this point
thinks that they're fully malicious in
what they're doing I pretty much think
so too
but there I want to give some of these
guys a little of the benefit of the
doubt that they're not doing this
maliciously I mean it sort of depends on
who are we talking about I I mean I
think we need to mention names here
because I mean I didn't want to mention
names but I mean I think that people
like Nam Chomsky and firkin Stein and
some folks nam client I think are
motivated by an ideology that they
actually care about which is like left
libertarianism anarchism against you
like United States
capitalism and things of that sort there
are people who are completely
disingenuous and completely dishonest
and they would misrepresent all of other
people views like I was I was I think I
think all my viewers probably know the
law there are people who like like for
example I highly debate on which was
featured on NPR winc about Islamophobia
in New York City and I said there are
progressive Muslims
moderate Muslims conservative Muslims
and extremists and then I was attacked
as being generalizing on Muslims and I
said that is exactly what I didn't do is
that that the statistics and the
research is being done is to avoid
generalization is when you say there's
like forty percent of Americans believe
in creationism you are literally saying
that 60 percent of them don't that means
you're not generalizing on Americans but
I kept repeating the same statement and
they kept saying that you are
generalizing on on Muslims as being
extremist and I kept repeating and they
kept saying the same thing and then they
go in and and and take something out of
context and then they put that in a meme
and share it on social media and somehow
I start getting attacked as we
generalizing on Muslims which is
completely disingenuous so I mean what
Sam has been dealing with is pretty much
what many of us who are actually talking
on the subject are dealing with is that
they are there purely that people are
purely disingenuous on the subject and
the they and actually it's kind of
interesting I think that they want to
create something what I was telling you
about Bashar Assad which is to destroy
all the nuanced approach of the liberal
critics of Islam and try to create the
battle between them and people like
Pamela Geller and Robert Spencer and all
of the far-right morons yeah and so that
way they will give people a binary
system in which they tell you know what
so the it's a war between far-right
fascist and Muslim innocent people so
which side you're gonna choose I love
that I love that framing because I mean
I'm getting email literally from all
over the world every day at this point
people talking about this middle ground
yes that's why I wanted to connect with
you and that's why I've been talking
about this stuff on the show because I
don't think most people are one side oh
yeah far left or the far right yeah most
people are right here yeah I mean for I
mean sometimes I mean on college
campuses it seems to me that the the
debate is also like is this very
polarized like and I was speaking at UC
Berkeley and Palo Alto and I I'm
speaking in Cornell
and I spoke in so many universities
before I can see that encompasses that
debate seems to be much more polarized
than it's on the media and I mean and
I'm guessing it's a lot of it's a lot of
white liberal fool on the left yes it is
upset with you yes which is which is
extremely so they always want to turn it
about them I was like III kept talking
about like issues like honor killing in
Iraq and and things of that sort
and then a guy jumps up there has to be
like a white liberal answer there has to
be this guy that'll be this dude shows
up at my venue whatever I go around this
stage to say no it's nothing to do with
with the culture something you do with
the religion there it's all about us
don't you know about the most has to
give me like the lecture about the motor
industry complex don't you know about
Wall Street don't pay taxes so so you're
not defending any of it exactly and
there's no correlation I mean I always
mentioned this example is like for
example if somebody let's say a radical
Muslim he walks in the let's say small
town in Arkansas or Mississippi and and
some redneck goes in and calls him like
a sign [ __ ] and like or he face any
racism there and then this person the
same person goes back to his house and
kills his daughter because she added the
guy on Facebook these two actions are
not related with each other is that what
some people think is that this guy
because he's facing oppression or racism
in some sort does lead let him to kill
his daughter which something that he
believed in probably before he came to
the United States and so yeah and they
think that everything is really centered
about oppression dynamics and and what's
happening is that now you cannot even
talk about the subject without claiming
to be victim and claiming to be
oppressed oh now like the whole
competition is that who is the most
victim anyway yeah that's like I don't
really go want to go to the identity
politics myself because it's like a very
crazy world it's like all that like now
I look at websites like tumblr or things
like this it was like somebody's
identification is like it's not like oh
I'm from there and I studied there
whatever it's like I am transgender
gender fluid I sexual this this
this is all about like his oppression
like how much he's oppressed and that is
what is now concerned about Rafi like
this um in some places so at some level
if you could lighten your skin and
change your biography away from Iraq
they'd like you a little bit more in a
weird way because they would think that
you're helping the oppressed yeah if
somehow being from the place that you're
now betraying like it's so warped yeah
it's very yeah I mean it's it's very I
mean as I said like they they look at
the wall the wall is it pretty much like
as a pyramid and and that's what like if
you if you got like the critical race
theory and gender theory and it's pretty
much all about class gender and race and
there's hardly any mention of ideology
and they so that's the way they see the
world so it is anything that the brown
person is doing even though that is his
culture that existed before the United
States or even Israel they say well this
is as a result of a brush he's an
oppressed by the somebody else on the
upper class but there is there are signs
of hope I mean for example give me some
hope we got about eight minutes left
let's yeah there are signs of hope
strong with is that if people go to
movement org and they see like the
continuous help like many of these
activists are doing if they're trying to
achieve things in the wrong countries
because like when I started becoming an
act and when I started like being
activist myself and and there were only
very few people I see on the internet
who were sacred or free thinkers so now
I look at Facebook and social media and
I see tons of thousands from Iraq from
Syria from Lebanon from all over the
Arab world countries like Tunisia has
voted for a secular country
despite of all the status quo of the
region is that is that many people think
that the Middle East is like one country
if it's like things are bad somewhere
it's bad everywhere else yeah and there
I mean places like in northern Iraq
which is that Kurdish region they seem
to be much more developed in terms of
Human Rights then they have women on the
ground fighting Isis yeah and turkeys
bombing them that's a whole yeah that's
that's the I mean I mean I mean as you
said like other are signs of pessimism
there because Turkey has a long secular
history and it is going backward with
but at the same time there is it I mean
I would say a very stronger position for
the article in Turkey that needs to be
supported and that's and that's I think
like if there is any message I would
give to the Liberals is like just don't
betray us here like the Liberals in the
way I should stand with their fellow
liberals on the east and and let's start
to apply DEP low standards and should
not stand with our enemies yes
that's if there's a message I can say
just don't stand if you don't want to
help just don't don't stand with our
enemies just make it kind of more easier
yeah well I love that message and I love
the fact that you brought it also back
to colleges because that's where I
started the show today because you know
we have all this stuff with yeah he's
going on on our Yad Missouri and yellow
arson cases exactly so that's what we
were talking about earlier and to me
it's it's a direct extension of what
these guys on the Left have done but
yeah they've made everyone so intolerant
yes is you're saying that now it's sort
of like they are now reaping what
they've sowed yeah it's kind of very
interesting it's like it's it's true a
slippery slope they're like you're gonna
see over a moment of time they're gonna
start attacking each other so it was it
was a female female white feminists
criticizing male white feminists as
being male priviledge now the female is
gonna get attacked by a transgender
disabled person of color attacking the
white transgender non-disabled so
they're gonna start attacking each other
and eventually nobody's going to be
allowed to speak because anybody's gonna
claim offense and that or they are
trivializing the experience of I mean
just ended with a funny story I mean
with with enough people like this yeah
somebody's like messaged me and he said
she said you should stop posting
pictures of your smiling on Facebook and
I said like yeah what's going on over
here and then she said when you post
pictures of you smiling you are
intentionally trying to trivialize the
experience of depressed people I was
like lol are you kidding me and then she
like blocked me immediately so
eventually the 44 does this person get
attacked by other people who we also
consider trivializing their experience
by like eating food with our hand
because
disabled so it's never ends never ends
and I think but I'm very glad that
there's now a counter movement to who
are the real liberals standing against
the their aggressives and because the
thing is I want everyone to be treated
equally me too shitty you don't have to
treat everyone as equally great treat
everyone equally as shitty that would be
fine with me yeah I want women wherever
they are to be treated equal whether
they are in the United States or whether
they're in Saudi Arabia I want gay
people to be treated equally well yeah I
want the white sis male to be treated
shitty that guy but yeah I mean that is
that is I mean that's what's really
motivated me when I start my activism is
is literally I mean the movement that I
started is called the global secular
humanist movement in which after seeing
so many conflicts about sectarianism and
and religious extremism rising up is
that the best way is to create a secular
society the secular liberal society in
which all people regardless of race or
gender or sexual orientation would live
equally without saying that oh it's
their culture and things of that sort
because I mean my motor as humans have
rights cultures and beliefs don't have
rice and yeah
ideas should be up to criticism and
debates and human rights have to be
sustained all across the board Wow all
right well that's that's a beautiful
ending you will always have my support
well thank you and I think I think we're
onto something because when even when I
was tweeting that you were coming on
people wanted to hear this and I think
you're right even though there's a lot
of bad stuff going on there is some hope
there and there's a lot of signs of hope
and and you know I think your show is
one of them all right well I appreciate
that
you guys can follow files let's Faisal
Alamut are on the Twitter all right
thanks for watching everybody we'll do
it again next week